we made about this channel a little bit earlier in the lesson and once again the required condition is pretty straightforward to
check as an exercise to work through if you would find that to be helpful consider the completely depolarizing
Channel which outputs the completely mixed state for every density Matrix input for this one four cross matrices
are required it's not possible to come up with a cross representation where n is three or less here's one choice that works and
here's another so the exercise is to verify that these choices work as well as to check that the required condition
is satisfied it's worth pointing out that the second alternative basically says that it's possible to completely depolarize a cubit or in other words to
completely randomize it by randomly choosing one of the four poly matrices including the identity and applying the
corresponding unitary operation to the Cubit and so the completely depolarizing channel is another example of a mixed
unitary channel the last of the three Channel representations that we'll cover is the Choy representation manduin Choy
is a mathematician who works on Matrix Theory and other topics and the Choy representation is named in his honor
based on a really elegant paper that he published in 1975 that in some sense ties all the stuff together the choit
representation of a channel f is a single Matrix that's conventionally denoted jfi and specifically if the
input system has n classical States and the output system has M classical States then the chy representation of f will be
an n * m by n * m Square Matrix before I tell you exactly how the Matrix is defined I'd like to mention a couple of
its Key properties which motivate the representation in a way that the actual definition itself might not at least on
the surface first unlike both Stein spring representations and cruss representations the chy representation
is a so-called faithful representation which means that every channel has just one of them and that's pretty important
because it says that two channels are the same if and only if their Choy representations are the same so if you
have two different descriptions of channels such as two different Stein spring representations or two different cruss representations or perhaps one of
each and you want to know if they are in fact the same channel you can just compute the Choy representation and
check whether or not they're equal the second property is that they are simple to check conditions on the Choy representation that are true if and only
if we have a valid channel that property isn't quite so special we can say the same thing about the other two representations but it's a good property
to have nevertheless and we'll discuss it further in more detail shortly one more thing to note about the Cho representation is that although we are
representing a channel by a matrix this Matrix does not directly represent the channel as a linear mapping in fact it's
actually more natural to associate the Choy representation with the density Matrix that represents a certain State
than it is to think about the Choy representation as describing a linear mapping it is however possible to recover the action of the channel from
its Tri representation using a pretty simple formula but it's not so simple as ordinary matrix
multiplication that's enough of a preamble let's get to the actual definition suppose that we have a channel fi from a system X to a system Y
and assume that the classical State set of the input system X is Sigma we're not going to need to refer to the classical State set of the the output system so
for the definition there's no need to name that one the Choy representation of fi is then defined by the expression
shown here on the screen we have a sum that ranges over all classical States A and B for the input system and we're
summing k a bra B tensored with the channel fi applied to k a bra B so this
representation is defined by a formula and there are a couple of different ways that we can think about this formula before I discuss them however let me
mention that sometimes the chart representation is defined in a slightly different way where the ordering of the two tensor factors is reversed meaning
that fi of k a bra appears as the first tensor Factor rather than the second but the two different ways of doing it are
equivalent up to this simple symmetry but what that means is that when you're using this representation it's a good
idea to clarify which ordering you're using this ordering is the way it's done in kcit and it's also better for
describing the representation visually in terms of block matrices so this is the one that going to go with to be more precise about the block Matrix
description if we assume that the classical State set Sigma consists of the integers from zero up to n minus one
for some positive integer n then we can alternatively write jfi as a block Matrix as is shown right here on the
screen in other words the Choy representation of fi is the Matrix we get by evaluating fi on each of the
input matrices that have exactly one entry equal to one with all of their entries zero and then arranging them
into a Matrix in a pretty natural way it may not be clear a priori why we would want to form a matrix like this but it
does turn out to be very useful one thing to notice is that the set containing the matrices k a bra b as
a and b both range over all integers from 0 to n minus one forms a basis for the space of all n byn matrices so if
you have this Matrix then you can certainly determine what fi does to an arbitrary n byn matrix by linearity
specifically by taking appropriate linear combinations of the blocks so the Matrix jfi does in fact uniquely
determine fi as a linear mapping another way to think about the Cho representation of a channel is that
it represents a state as a density Matrix when it's normalized specifically by dividing it by the number of
classical states of the input system which I'll continue to denote by lowercase n this will always give us a
density Matrix which is often referred to as the choice state of the channel here's how this works in more detail
imagine first that we have two identical copies of the input system and we consider the quantum State Vector s
displayed on the screen which represents a so-called maximally entangled state of this pair of identical systems for
instance if Sigma is the binary alphabet then this is a f+ state but we can think about an analogously defined state for
any choice of Sigma and what we get is a state that's highly entangled and in fact it's as entangled as you can get
given this choice of systems to obtain the density Matrix representation of the state we multiply the state Vector to its conjugate transpose as usual and
this is what it looks like and finally if we think about the Choy representation of the channel divided by n then we see that it's the state that
we would obtain if we were to apply the channel fi to the second system in the form of a figure here's
what this looks like we have two copies of the system X in this maximally entangled State s the channel f is
applied to the second system which is the one on the top in the diagram and the resulting state is the choice state of five of course we wouldn't normally
give the same name to two different systems like this it's generally not helpful to give the same name to two different things but it does make sense